[SQUEAKING][RUSTLING][CLICKING]
ERIK DEMAINE: Today we're
going to, in one lecture,
cover an entire field, which
is computational complexity.
It's sort of-- it
meets algorithms
in an interesting way, which
is, algorithms is mostly
about showing how to
solve problems well
and showing that you can
solve a problem well.
And computational complexity
is more about the lower bound
side, proving that
you can't prove--
you can't solve a
problem very well,
you can't find a good
algorithm to solve it.
We've seen a little bit about
lower bounds several lectures
ago, proving search and
sorting lower bounds
in a bounded branching
decision tree model.
But these are much stronger
notions of badness.
This is not about n versus n
log n or constant versus log n.
This is about polynomial
versus exponential,
which has been the sort
of bread-and-butter model
in this class.
Polynomial is a
good running time,
and we're always
striving for that.
Exponential is usually
pretty trivial to get.
And so we're going to talk
about some different--
they're called
complexity classes
that talk about this
issue and different ways
to prove hardness.
This is a pretty
high-level lecture,
so you're not going
to be expected
to be able to prove hardness.
But you'll get a flavor
of what it's like,
and this will segue nicely
into other follow-on classes,
which is-- we're at pretty
much the end of 006,
so natural to talk about what
other things you might study.
One result we'll prove today
is that most problems actually
have no algorithm, which
is kind of shocking,
and lots of other fun things.
So let's get started
with the notion of P.
This is the set of all problems
solvable in polynomial time.
We talked about
what polynomial time
means a bunch last lecture.
So just recall that
polynomial time
means polynomial in the problem
size, which I'll denote as n
here, the number of
words in your input.
OK, so these are the problems
that are efficiently solvable.
P is the set of all of them.
And for contrast, EXP is the
set of all problems solvable
in exponential time.
It's the problems solvable
Exponential here
means something like 2
to the n to the constant.
That's one reasonable
definition of exponential,
so just the exponentiation
of this-- of polynomial.
So as you might expect, most--
every problem that we've
talked about in this class
so far can be solved in
exponential time rather easily.
And algorithms, in
some sense, is about
distinguishing these two,
which problems are in P
versus are in say EXP minus P.
So to formalize
this a little bit,
I'm going to draw
a picture, which
is a bit of a
simplification of reality,
but for the purposes of
this class will suffice,
and I think is a
really helpful way
to think about things, which
is to have a big axis for--
a single axis for, how
hard is your problem,
what is the difficulty
of solving your problem?
And I want to be sure to leave--
so the easiest
problems are over here.
And each problem is
a dot on this axis.
Hardest problems are
way down the line.
And I want to make sure to leave
enough space for all the things
that I care about.
So P, I'm just going to
call this segment up front.
And then I'm going
to have a bigger
thing for exponential time.
So this is just to say that
P is nested inside EXP.
Every problem that can be
solved in polynomial time
can also be solved
in exponential time
because polynomial is less
than or equal to exponential.
These are just upper bounds.
Being an EXP means you're
somewhere from this line
to the left.
Being in P means you're
somewhere from this line
to the left, in
terms of difficulty.
But formally, we would write
P is contained in EXP as sets.
In fact, they're also known to
be different from each other.
There are problems that can be
solved in exponential time that
cannot be solved
in polynomial time.
For example-- I'll
put that here, sure.
For example, n by n chess
is in exponential time,
but not polynomial time.
So what is the n
by chess problem?
This is, I give you
an n by n chessboard,
and I describe to
you a position.
Here's where all the
white pieces are.
black pieces are.
You can have an arbitrary number
of queens and bishops and pawns
of each color, of
course, up to n
squared of them so they
don't overlap each other.
And I want to know, does
white win from this position?
Let's say it's white to move.
Can white win?
And that problem can be
solved in an exponential time
by exploring the entire
tree of all possible games.
But it cannot-- but you can
prove that it cannot be solved
in polynomial time.
So that's a nice example.
A more positive
example, so to speak,
is negative weight
cycle detection.
I guess it's literally negative,
but it's morally positive.
Negative weight cycle detection
is the following problem.
I give you a graph, a
directed graph with weights,
and I want to know, does
it have a negative weight
cycle, yes or no?
And this problem is in?
AUDIENCE: P.
ERIK DEMAINE: P, because we
saw a polynomial time algorithm
for this.
You run Bellman-Ford
on an augmented graph.
So this is an example of a
problem we know how to solve.
This whole class
is full of examples
that we know how to
solve in polynomial time.
But this is a nice, non-trivial
and succinct one to phrase.
It's also an example
of a decision problem.
A lot of-- basically all the
problems I'll talk about today
are decision problems, like
we talked about last class,
meaning, the answer
is just yes or no.
Can white win from this
position, yes or no?
Is there a negative
weight cycle, yes or no?
Tetris we can also
formulate as a problem.
This is a version of
Tetris that we might call
perfect information Tetris.
Suppose I give you
a Tetris board.
It has some garbage left
over from your past playing,
or maybe it started that way.
And I give you the sequence of
n pieces that are going to come.
And I want to
know, can I survive
this sequence of n pieces?
Can you place each
of these pieces
as they fall such that
you never overflow
the top of the board
on an n by n board?
This problem can be solved
in exponential time.
But we don't know whether it can
be solved in polynomial time.
We will talk about
that more in a moment.
It's a problem that
very likely is not in P,
but we can't actually
prove it yet.
All right, so there's
one other class
I want to define at this point.
And we'll get to
a fourth one also.
But R is the class
of all problems that
can be solved in finite time.
R stands for finite.
R stands for
recursive, actually.
This is a notion
by Church way back
in the foundations of computing.
As we know, we write recursive
algorithms to solve problems.
In the beginning, that
was the only way to do it.
Now we have other
ways with loops.
But they're all effectively
recursion in the end.
So R is all the problems
that can be solved
in finite time on any computer.
So very general,
this should include
everything we care about.
And it's bigger than
EXP, but includes
problems that take doubly
exponential time or whatever.
So I will draw a region
for R. So everything--
it includes P. It includes EXP.
And so we also have
containment but not
equal R. There's, of course,
many classes in between.
You could talk
about problems that
take double A exponential time,
and that would have a thing
in between here.
Or there's also--
between P and EXP
there's a lot of
different things.
We will talk about one of them.
But before we get to the
finer side of things,
let me talk in particular about
R. So we have a nice example,
we being computational
complexity theory--
or I guess this is usually just
called theoretical computer
science--
has a problem.
And if you're interested
in this, you can take 6041,
I think.
That doesn't sound right.
That's a probability.
It'll come to me.
We have an explicit
problem that is not in R.
So this class has been
all about problems that
are in P. You have the number?
AUDIENCE: 6045.
ERIK DEMAINE: 6045, thank you.
It's so close to this class.
Or it's so close to 6046,
which is the natural successor
to this class.
So in 6045 we talk about this.
So this class is all
about problems that
are in P, which is very easy.
But in fact, there are
problems way out here beyond R.
And here is one
such problem, which
we won't prove here today.
It takes a whole
lecture to prove this.
Given a computer program,
does it ever halt?
Does it ever terminate?
This would be a great thing
if we knew how to solve.
It's basically an
infinite loop detector.
If your problem
doesn't halt, then it
has an infinite
loop of some sort.
And you'd like to
tell your user, hey,
you have a bug in your program.
So this is one part
of bug detection.
And it's impossible.
There is no algorithm
that always--
that solves all inputs
to this problem.
Maybe given one program that,
say, has 0 lines of code,
it could solve that.
It says, yeah, that
one terminates.
And maybe you can detect
simple kinds of infinite loops.
So there's some inputs,
some computer programs
that you could detect.
But there's no one algorithm
that solves all inputs.
This is kind of sad news.
We call such problems
uncomputable.
This is just another
word for being not in R.
OK, and next thing
I'd like to do
is prove to you
that most decision
problems are uncomputable,
or sketcher proof.
So remember, decision
problems are problems where
the answer is just yes or no.
This is a very special
kind of problem.
And even those, almost all
of them, cannot be solved.
So halting is an example
of a problem we want--
we can't solve.
This whole class, this 006, is
about problems we can solve.
But today I'm going to show
you that, actually, those
are in the minority.
Most problems
cannot be computed.
This is very strange and
also a little depressing.
So we'll talk more
about that in a moment.
First let me argue
why this is the case.
So I'm going to be
a little informal
about what exactly
is a computer program
and what exactly is
a decision problem.
But roughly, all I need
to do, the only level
of precision I need is just
to count how many are there.
What is a computer program?
Well, it's usually a file.
What's a file?
It's like a string
of characters.
What's a character?
It's a string of bits.
So a program is just, in
the end, a string of bits,
finite string of bits.
We all understand that.
Whatever language you
define, in the end,
every program is just
a string of bits.
And a string of bits we can
translate into a number.
So we can convert between
strings of bits and numbers.
When I say number, I
mean what's usually
called a natural number
or a non-negative integer.
This is usually represented
by bold board bold--
blackboard bold
capital N. So this
is just 0, 1, 2, and so on.
Now, what about
decision problems?
Decision problem
is a specification
of what we want to solve.
So we can think of it as
saying, for every input,
is the answer yes or no?
That's literally what
a decision problem is.
The only question
is, what is an input?
And we've talked about inputs
and the size of inputs.
And there's lots of different
ways to measure them.
But in the end, we can think
of an input as a string of bits
also.
It's just a file.
So a decision
problem is a function
from inputs to yes or no.
And inputs we're going
to say, well, that's
a string of bits, which we can
associate with a number in N.
So here we can start
to tie things together.
So in other words, a program
is a finite string of bits,
and a problem is, in some sense,
an infinite string of bits
because there are infinitely
many possible inputs.
And for each of them,
we specify yes or no.
So this is basically an
infinite string of bits.
So we can imagine
011010001110, infinitely.
Just some-- for every string
of bits, we can say, OK,
if your input is the number
0, here's the answer--
no.
If your input is the number
1, then the answer is yes.
If your input is the
number 2, your answer
is yes, and so on
down this line.
Every infinite string
of bits corresponds
to exactly one
decision problem, which
specifies for every possible
input integer, which
corresponds to a string of bits,
what is the answer, yes or no?
So this may seem subtle, or it
may seem like not a big deal.
This is a finite string of bits.
This is an infinite
string of bits.
But mathematics has well
studied this problem.
And infinite strings of bits,
there are very many of them,
infinitely many.
It's not surprising.
There are also
infinitely many integers.
So maybe it doesn't
seem that deep.
But there's a difference
in infinitude.
Programs and integers
are countably infinite.
And infinite strings of bits
are what's called uncountable.
I think the most
intuitive way to see
this is, an infinite
string of bits,
if I put a decimal or a
binary point in front,
this encodes a real
number between 0 and 1.
So this is roughly
a real number in 01.
And when I'm writing
approximately equal here,
this really goes
in both directions.
Given a decision problem, I
can define a string of bits,
of course giving me the
answer for all inputs.
And I can convert that into a
real number between 0 and 1.
But also the other direction,
if I take any real number,
that is a corresponding
decision problem.
These are 1 to 1
bijection between them.
And the bad news is, real
numbers are uncountable,
and natural numbers
are countable,
which means there's a lot more
of these than there are these.
So one way you might
phrase this is, informally,
the number of natural
numbers is way smaller
than the number of real numbers.
And so from that, we derive that
most problems are unsolvable,
because every program solves
exactly one decision problem.
We can also run a
program, conceptually,
on all possible inputs,
and we will figure out
what function at solving.
And if we don't allow random
numbers in our program, which
I'm not here, then every program
solves exactly one decision
problem.
Possibly, it's even worse for
us because multiple programs
probably solve the
same decision problem.
They're just-- they add
irrelevant lines of code
or they don't do
anything different.
Or you run Bellman-Ford
versus running Bellman-Ford
five times, you'll
get the same result.
And that's actually the
bad direction for us.
We'd like to know whether
there is a program that
solves every decision problem.
And because there are
only this many programs
and this many decision
problems, it just-- there
aren't enough to go around.
So most-- what's the phrasing?
Not nearly enough programs for
all problems, and so there's
no assignment of
programs to problems
because there's just
too many problems.
More money, more
problems, I guess.
So when I first
saw this result, I
was shocked and dismayed that--
why are we even doing computer
science if most problems can't
be solved?
Luckily, it seems like most
of the problems we care about
can be solved.
That's what this
class is all about.
And in fact, even the
problems that seem really,
really hard for us to solve,
like n by n chess, where we can
prove it takes
exponential time, there
is an algorithm to solve chess.
It's just really slow.
And this is a statement
about, most problems
can even be solved
in finite time
no matter how much
time you give them.
So it's not all bad.
Luckily, most
problems we care about
are in R. I don't know why.
This is sort of a
mystery of life.
But it's good news.
Or it's why we keep persevering
trying to solve problems
with algorithms.
AUDIENCE: Is it because
when we state problems,
the statement tends to be small?
ERIK DEMAINE: Well, this--
so the question
was, maybe it's just
because these short
statement problems are easy.
But this is a pretty short
statement, and it's hard.
I think-- I don't have
a great reason why.
I wish I understood.
There's a general
result that if you
have any question about
the program itself, then
there's no algorithm
to solve it.
Basically, any non-trivial
question about programs is
hard, is not in R. And
I guess if you took--
if you imagine taking a
random statement of a problem,
then maybe this will
be in the middle of it
with some probability.
Maybe that's why most.
But this is a very
strong notion of most.
There are so many more real
numbers than natural numbers
that--
I don't know.
I want to add one more class
to this picture, which is NP.
It nestles in between P and EXP.
So we know that P is
contained in or equal to NP.
And NP is contained
in or equal to EXP.
We don't know whether there's
a quality here or here.
Probably not, but
we can't prove it.
But what is this class?
A couple of different
ways to define it--
you might find one way or
the other more intuitive.
They're equivalent.
So as long as you understand at
least one of them, it's good.
NP is just a class
of decision problems.
So I define P and
EXP and R arbitrary.
They can be problems
with any kind of output.
But NP only makes sense
for decision problems.
And it's going to look almost
like the definition of P--
problem solvable
in polynomial time.
We've just restricted
to decision problems.
But we're going to
allow a strange kind
of computer or
algorithm, which I
like to call a lucky algorithm.
And this is going to relate
to the notion of guessing
that we talked about for
the last four lectures
in dynamic programming.
With dynamic programming,
we said, oh, there
are all these different
choices I could make.
What's the right choice?
I don't know, so I'd
like to make a guess.
And what that meant in terms
of a real algorithm is,
we tried all of
the possibilities,
and then took the max
or the OR or whatever
over all those possibilities.
And so we were--
but what we were
simulating is something
that I call a lucky algorithm,
which can make guesses
and always makes
the right guess.
This is a computer that
is impossible to buy.
It would be great if you could
buy a computer that's lucky.
But we don't know how to
build such a computer.
So what does this mean?
So informally, it
means your algorithm
can make lucky guesses, and it
always makes the right guess.
And whereas in DP, we had
to try all the options
and spend time for all of
them, the lucky algorithm only
has to spend time on the lucky
guess, on the correct guess.
More formally, this is called
a non-deterministic model
of computation.
And this N is the--
the N in non-determinism
is the N for NP.
So this is non-deterministic
polynomial time.
So algorithm can make guesses.
And then in the end, it
should output yes or no.
Like say if you're exploring a
maze, this algorithm could say,
should I go left or go right?
I'm going to guess whether
to go left or go right.
And let's say it guesses left.
And so then it just goes left.
And then it reaches
another junction.
It says, should I
go left or right?
And it'll say, I'll
guess, and it'll
say, guess right this time.
And in the end, if I get to some
dead end maybe and I say no,
or if I get to the destination
I'm trying to get to,
I say yes.
So that's a
non-deterministic algorithm.
And what does it mean
to run that algorithm?
What does it mean for
the guesses to be lucky?
Here's what it means.
These guesses are guaranteed--
which way you end up going is
guaranteed to lead you to a yes
if there is one--
if possible.
So in my maze analogy,
if my destination
is reachable from
my source, then
I'm guaranteed, whenever
I guessed left or right,
I will choose a path that
leads me to my destination.
Whereas, if the destination
is in some disconnected part
of the maze and I
can't get there,
then I don't know
what the guesses do.
It doesn't really matter.
Because no matter what I do,
I'll end up in a dead end
and say no.
That's the model.
As long as you have an algorithm
that always outputs yes or no
in polynomial time-- because
we're only talking about
polynomial time,
lucky algorithms--
if there's any way
to get to a yes,
then your machine
will magically find it
without having to spend any
time to make these decisions.
So it's a pretty
magical computer,
and it's not a computer
that exists in real life.
But it's a computer that's
great to program on.
It's very powerful.
You could solve lots
of things with it.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: If you had
this magical computer,
it can guess whether
it's yes or no,
why doesn't it just
answer the question?
ERIK DEMAINE: Right.
So what if we-- so
a nice check is,
does this make all problems
trivial, all decision problems?
Maybe I should
say, well, I don't
know whether the
answer to the problem
is yes or no, so I'll
just guess yes or no.
This is problematic because--
so I might say, it
will guess A or B,
and if I choose the A
option, I will output yes,
and if I choose the B
option, I will output no.
In this model, that algorithm
will always output yes.
Because what it's
saying is, if there's
any way to get to a yes
answer, I will do that way.
And so such an algorithm
that tries to cheat and just
guess the whole
answer to the problem
will actually end
up always saying
yes, which means
it doesn't solve
a very interesting problem.
It only solves
the problem, which
is represented by the
bit vector 1111111,
where all the answers are yes.
But good check.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Does there
have to be a bound
of a number of things it has
to choose between when it
[AUDIO OUT]
ERIK DEMAINE: Yes.
AUDIENCE: Does it have an
exponential number of them?
ERIK DEMAINE: Exponential
number of choices is OK.
I usually like to think
of it, as you can only
guess one bit at a time.
But we're allowed
polynomial time,
so you're actually
allowed to guess
polynomial number of bits.
At that point, you can guess
over an exponential size space,
but not more than exponential.
So it's-- yeah, polynomial
time let's say in the one-bit
guessing model.
What did I say?
Makes guesses-- let's
add binary here.
Otherwise we get some other
class, which I don't want.
OK, let's do an example, a real
example of such an algorithm
that's useful, which is Tetris.
So I claim Tetris is
in NP because there
is a lucky algorithm and
non-deterministic polynomial
time algorithm that can
solve the Tetris game.
So again, you're
given a board, you're
given some sequence
of pieces, and you
want to know whether
there's some way
to place the pieces
that lets you survive.
And so what I'm going to
do is, for each piece,
I'm going to guess
how to place it.
So for the first
piece, I'm going
to guess how far left
or right do I move it.
Then I let it fall one step.
Maybe I rotate it.
I choose a sequence of moves
among left, right, down,
rotate right, rotate left.
And all along the way, I
check, is that move valid?
If the move is invalid at any
point, I just say, return no.
And then if the piece gets
nestled into a good spot,
I continue to the next piece.
I do the same thing, guess
all the possible things
I could do to that.
Again, I only need to
guess one bit at a time.
And I'll only need to do a
polynomial number of guesses,
like a linear number of guesses,
for each piece about where
it falls in, so maybe a
quadratic number of guesses
overall.
And then at the
end, if I survived--
oh, I also have to
check if a line clears.
Then I clear the line.
And if in the end I
survive, I return yes.
So this is a
non-deterministic algorithm.
So I would say, check
the rules of the game.
And if we survive, return yes.
And if at any point we violate
the rules-- for example,
we go off the top of the board--
we return no.
So this is an algorithm
that sometimes returns
no and sometimes
returns yes depending
on what choices you make.
And this model
guarantees, if there's
any way to get to a
yes, it will find it.
If I swapped these
answers, if I returned yes
when I violated the rules and
returned no if I survived,
this would be an
uninteresting algorithm.
Because it's very easy
to lose in Tetris.
The hard part is to survive.
If I say, is there any way to
play the game in such a way
that I violate the rules, then,
of course, the answer is yes.
You can just stack pieces
and go off the top.
There's an asymmetry in this
definition of yes versus no.
It always finds yes
answers if possible.
It doesn't always find
no answers if possible.
So it's very important the way
that I wrote these questions.
It's important that I define
Tetris as the problem of,
can I survive?
The problem of
can I not survive,
is it impossible to survive,
that's a different question.
That problem is not
in NP, probably.
OK, so slight subtlety
there, yes versus no.
Let me give you the
other definition of NP.
So if this one's
confusing, which--
although I prefer
this definition.
Most people do not.
So this is confusing.
Let's do the other definition.
So another definition is that
NP is a set of decision problems
that can be checked
in polynomial time.
This actually came up
in the last lecture
where we talked
about subset sum.
I said, here's a
bunch of integers,
here's a target integer,
and I can prove to you
that this integer can be
represented as a sum of numbers
from my subset of numbers from
my set, because here they are.
I gave you this plus this plus
this equals the target sum.
And so that is a solution,
in some sense, that can
be checked for a yes example.
If I can represent my number
as a subset sum of a given set,
it's easy for me to
prove that to you.
And you can check it just
by adding up the numbers
and checking that each
number was in the set.
Whereas no instances, I had
an example of a target sum
that could not be reached.
And the only reason I
knew that is because I
had brute-forced the thing.
And there's no succinct way to
prove to you that that number
can't be represented.
A similar thing with Tetris,
what I would say is--
so this is version
1, version 2--
for Tetris is
that, a certificate
for a yes input of
Tetris is a sequence
of moves for the pieces.
OK, if it's possible
to survive in Tetris,
I can prove it to you.
I can just play the game and
show you that I survived.
No answers, I don't
know, it's hard to prove
to you that I can't survive
a given sequence of pieces.
But yes answers are easy.
I just show you, here's the
sequence of button presses
I'll do for this piece,
then for this piece,
then for this piece.
Notice it's exactly
the same thing
that I guessed in the
beginning of this algorithm.
And then I did some other
work to implement the rules.
And similarly, if I gave
you a certificate, which
is the things that I wanted to
guess of how to play the game,
I can check this certificate
by just implementing
the rules of Tetris and
seeing whether I survived.
And if you violate the rules
at any point, you say no.
And if you survive,
you return yes.
That's what's called a
verification algorithm.
So let me formalize this notion.
Given a problem input
plus a certificate,
like that one over there,
there is a polynomial time--
so this is yet
another definition.
This is what I mean by
this definition of NP--
verification algorithm that
satisfies two properties.
One is, for every yes input--
so every input where the
answer is yes to the problem--
there exists a certificate such
that the verifier says yes.
So this is saying, it's
possible to prove to me
that an answer is yes,
because if you ever
have an input that the
answer happens to be yes,
you can prove it to me by
giving me a certificate.
There's always some certificate
that proves the answer's yes.
Because the verifier, which runs
in regular polynomial time--
this is a regular,
old-fashioned,
down-to-earth
verification algorithm,
polynomial time in
our usual sense--
it will say yes.
And furthermore, the yes
answers from the verifier
are actually meaningful, because
if I ever give it a no input,
it always says no, no matter
what certificate I give it.
So this should really
formalize what all this means.
It's equivalent to the
previous definition.
This is saying that proofs
exist for yes instances.
And this is saying that proofs
don't exist for no instances,
meaning there are
no false proofs.
So if the verifier
ever outputs yes,
you know that the answer
to your problem is yes.
But if it outputs
no, you're not sure.
Maybe you got the
certificate wrong
because we only know there's
some certificate where
the verifier will say yes.
Or maybe it was a no
input, and then it
didn't matter what
certificate you used.
But it's nice, because
it says on, say, Tetris,
if I give you the
sequence of pieces,
it's very easy to write down a
verifier which just implements
the rules of Tetris.
And so then you can at least
check whether a solution
is valid in the yes case.
In the no case, we don't
have anything useful.
So NP is a structure,
some additional structure
about the yes inputs
in your problem.
And a lot of decision
problems are in NP.
A lot of the problems
that we care about
can be phrased as an NP problem.
As long as it's a
decision problem,
usually, answering yes or no
is provable, like subset sum,
like Tetris.
These are all problems
where, if the answer is yes,
I can give you a
convincing proof why.
And it turns out a lot--
so a lot of problems
fall into this NP setting.
And so we have some tools
for talking about problems
being hard with respect to NP.
Let me first talk a
little bit about P.
Does not equal
NP, question mark.
A lot of people conjecture
that P does not equal NP.
It's sort of a
standard conjecture
in theoretical computer science.
But we don't know how to prove
whether P equals NP or does not
equal NP.
And so in this picture,
I've drawn the hypothesis,
which is that NP is a strictly
bigger region than P is.
But we don't actually
know whether there
are problems in this region.
We don't know whether
there are problems
in this region
between NP and EXP.
We conjecture there
are problems here
and there are problems here.
There's definitely problems
here or problems here,
but we don't know which one.
Because we know P
does not equal EXP,
but we don't know
whether P equals NP,
and we don't know
whether P equals EXP.
If you could prove that P does
not equal NP, or disprove it,
you would win $1 million, which
not that much money these days.
But you would be famous
to for the rest of time
if you could ever prove this.
Every year, there's
usually a crackpot proof
that doesn't work out.
Some of them go to me.
Please don't send them.
And anyway, it's a
very hard problem.
It is sort of the core problem
in theoretical computer
science, how to prove
P does not equal NP.
But for the most part,
we just assume it.
Now, what does this
conjecture mean?
It essentially means-- the
way I like to say it is,
you cannot engineer luck.
Because NP problems
are problems you
can solve by lucky algorithms.
P are problems you can solve
by regular old algorithms.
And so if P equalled
NP, it means
luck doesn't buy you
anything, which seems weird.
If I can magically make
these super powerful guesses,
then I can solve the
problem that that's
NP, that seems
super powerful, way
more powerful than
regular algorithms,
where we have to actually
brute-force and try
all the choices.
And so it seems pretty solid
that P does not equal NP.
That's my-- of course, we
don't know how to prove it.
Another phrasing
is that it's harder
to come up with proofs
than it is to check them,
from a mathematical perspective.
This is equivalent to
P does not equal NP.
So that's why you
should believe it.
Now, let's go over here.
The next notion is NP-hardness.
So in particular,
I want to claim--
this is a theorem that
exists in the literature--
that if P does not equal
NP, then Tetris is not NP.
So I said right here,
Tetris is in EXP,
but we don't know
whether it's in NP.
But in fact, we
conjecture it is not NP
because we conjecture
that P does not equal NP.
If you could prove
this conjecture--
and there's a lot of theorems
that are conditioned assuming P
does not equal NP--
then we get some nice results,
like Tetris cannot be solved
in polynomial time.
It cannot figure out whether
I can win a Tetris game
in polynomial time
in the input size.
Why?
This is a consequence of
another theorem, which
is that Tetris is NP-hard.
I'm going to define
NP-hard informally first,
and then I'll define it slightly
more formally in a second.
But this means,
roughly, that Tetris is
as hard as all problems in NP.
So let me draw this
in the picture.
So NP-hard is this part.
Did I leave myself enough room?
Maybe not.
Well, we'll squeeze it in.
There's another region
here for EXP-hard.
So your problem being in
NP was a positive result.
It says you're no more
difficult than this line.
You're either at this
position or to the left.
Being in P was also
a positive statement.
It says you're here
or to the left.
Being in P is better
than being in NP
because this is
a subset of that.
NP-hard is a lower bound.
It says, you are at this point,
at this level of difficulty,
or to the right.
And so it goes from here off
to infinity in difficulty.
And EXP-hard says
you're at least
as hard as the right
extent of the EXP set,
or you're harder than
that, in a sense that we
will formalize in a moment.
And this place right here,
as you might imagine,
is kind of interesting.
It's exactly where
NP meets NP-hard.
This thing is
called NP-complete.
You probably have heard
about NP-completeness,
a famous notion.
And this is what it means.
It is, the problems
that are in NP--
so they have a lucky
algorithm that solves them,
they can be verified,
there are certificates
that can be verified--
and they are NP-hard.
So they're in NP, and they
are the hardest among problems
in NP.
Now, they're not
the hardest problem.
There are actually many
problems right here
at this single level of
difficulty called NP-complete.
Among them is Tetris.
There are many others, which
I will list in a moment.
So that is NP-completeness.
So because these problems are
the hardest problems in NP,
if there's any problems
here in between--
in NP minus P, then
these must be among them.
And so if you assume
that P does not
equal NP, as most
people do, then
you know that all problems
at this right-most extreme
of NP, the hardest of
the problems in NP,
they must not be NP.
And that's why I can say,
if P does not equal NP,
Tetris is not NP, and also, any
NP complete problem is not NP.
OK, what does "as hard as" mean?
This is our good
friend reductions.
We talked about reductions
a lot in this class.
Reductions are the easy
way to use algorithms.
You just take your problem
and reduce it to a problem
you already know how to solve.
You take the input to some
problem that you want to solve,
and you convert it into an
input to some other problem,
like single source shortest
paths or something like that
that you already have an
algorithm for solving.
So if you have an algorithm
that solves problem B,
you can convert that
into a solution for B.
And a reduction should
also tell me how to--
given a solution to B,
how to convert it back
into a solution for A. And
when I say solution here,
I actually mean certificate
from over there.
So how-- so if I--
so if I have-- so reduction
consists of these two pieces--
how to convert an input
at A to an input for B,
and given a solution
to B, how to convert it
to a solution to A.
Let me give you some examples of
reductions you've already seen.
You've seen a lot of them.
If I have unweighted
shortest paths on the left--
unweighted single
source shortest paths--
I can reduce that to
weighted shortest paths.
How?
AUDIENCE: Set all
the weights to 1.
ERIK DEMAINE: Set
all the weights to 1.
So here I'm given a
graph without weights.
If I set all the
weights to 1, that
turns it into an input for a
weighted single source shortest
paths.
So if you didn't know
how to solve this,
you could solve it
by converting it.
If you've already written,
say, a Dijkstra algorithm,
you could apply it to solve
unweighted single source
shortest paths.
Now, we know a faster
way to solve this,
but it's only a
log factor faster.
And here we're talking about
polynomial versus exponential.
So this is a valid reduction.
It's not the most
interesting one
from an algorithmic standpoint,
but it is an algorithm.
Another one we've
seen is, if you
have integer
weights in the left,
you can convert
that to unweighted
on the right, positive
integer weights,
by subdividing each
edge of weight W
into W edges of no weight.
So that's maybe a little
bit less efficient.
It depends what the
sum of the weights are.
Another version that we've seen
is longest path in a graph.
We can-- weighted path we
can reduce to shortest path
in a graph, weighted by
negating all the weights.
We did this in some of the
dynamic programming things.
Like oh, longest path on a DAG?
We can convert that into
shortest path on a DAG
just by negating
all the weights.
So these are all examples
of converting one problem
to another.
Usually, you convert from--
for algorithms, you
convert from a problem
you want to solve into a
problem that you already
know how to solve.
But it turns out the same
tool reductions can be used
to prove negative results too.
And in this case, we're going
to reduce from a problem that we
think cannot be solved and
reduce it to the problem that
we're interested in solving.
So let me write more
precisely what this means.
If you can find a
reduction like this,
it means that
solving A is at least
as easy as solving B. Because
I could solve A, in particular,
by converting it into B, solving
B, and then converting it back
to a solution to A. So in
other words, if I can solve B,
I can solve A, which I
can phrase informally as,
A is at least as easy as B.
And now using grammar,
contrapositive
whatever, this is the same thing
as saying that B is at least as
hard as A. And this is what I
mean by at least as hard as.
So this is my definition
of at least as hard,
in this notion of NP-hardness.
So what NP-hard means
is that I'm at least as
hard as all problems in NP.
So what that means is,
every problem in NP
can be reduced to Tetris,
which is kind of funny.
But in particular, that
means that if there's
an algorithm for Tetris,
there's an algorithm
for all problems in NP.
And so that's actually
the contrapositive
of this statement.
So this is saying, if
there's a polynomial--
if I take the contrapositive
of this, this is saying,
if there's a polynomial
time algorithm for Tetris,
then P equals NP, there's
a polynomial time algorithm
for every problem in NP.
And the way we prove
that is by reductions.
We take an arbitrary problem in
NP, and we reduce it to Tetris.
Luckily, that's not as hard as
it sounds because it's already
been done once.
There is already a
reduction from NP to--
from all problems in NP to
singular problems out there,
the NP-complete problems.
There is some first
NP-complete problem, which
I guess is the Turing machine.
It's basically simulating
a lucky algorithm,
so it's kind of a not
very interesting problem.
But from that problem,
if you can reduce it
to any other problem,
you know that problem
is NP-hard as well.
And so briefly, I want to show
you some examples of that here.
So I want to start
out with a problem
that I'm just going to
assume is NP-complete.
And it's called 3-partition.
One way to phrase it is, I
give you a bunch of integers--
I think I have it written down
over here, also the board.
I give you n integers, and
I'd like to divide them up
into n over 3 groups of size 3,
such that each group of size 3
has the same sum.
And it's written
there on the board.
So you can also think of this
as the following problem.
I give you a bunch of rectangles
that are a side length--
or a bunch of sticks, let's
say, of varying lengths,
and I want to group them up
like on the right diagram,
so in groups of 3, such that
the total length of each group
is exactly the same.
This is just a problem.
And just believe for now
that it is NP-complete.
I won't prove that.
But what I'd like to show you
is a reduction from this problem
to another problem--
solving jigsaw puzzles.
So you might think
jigsaw puzzles
are really easy, and especially
easy if I lose the projector.
But in fact, if you
have a jigsaw puzzle
where some of the
matches are ambiguous,
if there's multiple pieces that
could fit against a given tab
or pocket, then I
claim I can represent
this 3-partition problem
by building little sticks,
like here.
So if I want to represent
a stick of length ai,
I'm just going to build an ai--
I didn't mention
they're all integers,
and they're
polynomial-sized integers.
I'm going to represent that
by ai different pieces here.
And the red tabs and
pockets are designed
to be unique global
to the puzzle,
like a regular jigsaw puzzle.
Given this piece on the left
and this tab on the right,
there's a unique pocket, there's
a piece with unique pocket
that fits perfectly
into that piece.
So this joining is forced.
And also this joining is forced.
But the blue tabs and
pockets are different.
They're all the same.
They're all identical.
And so if I build
this frame using
the red unique assignments,
and I build these rectangles,
if I want to pack these
rectangles into this rectangle,
that's exactly the 3-partition
problem, with some details
that I didn't fill in.
But it turns out you'd
be forced to group these
into groups of size 3,
something like this,
with varying lengths.
OK, so that's an
example of a reduction.
If you believe the
3-partition is NP-hard,
this proves to you that
jigsaw puzzles are NP-hard,
something you may
not have known.
Every time you solve
a jigsaw puzzle,
you can feel good
about yourself now,
especially if it
has ambiguous mates.
Next is Tetris.
So here is a reduction from
the same 3-partition problem,
which is one of my favorite
problems, to Tetris.
It starts out with
this strange board.
It has a bunch of columns
here where I could put pieces.
So I'm not allowed to put
pieces in these dark regions.
They all have height
T. T is the target sum
that we want all
of the numbers to--
all of the triples of
numbers to add up to.
And there's n over
3 of these slots
where I can try to put pieces.
And it's-- because of this
thing over on the right,
there's no way to clear
lines in this game.
And now to represent
a single number ai,
I'm going to give you
this sequence of pieces,
which starts with an L piece.
And then it has ai
repetitions of this pattern,
and then it ends with
these two pieces.
And so what ends up
happening is that--
this is in the
intended solution--
you first place an L at the
bottom of one of these buckets,
and then you repeat this
pattern in this nice way.
And it fills up the ai,
roughly, height of this bucket.
And then at the end, you
have to put the I here.
And what this ends
up guaranteeing
is that all of these pieces
go into a single bucket.
You can check.
It's tedious.
But if you tried to put
some of these pieces
in one bucket and other
pieces in a different bucket,
you would lose some space,
and then you would die.
So if you want to survive, you
have to put all these pieces
into one bucket.
And so again, we're just
stacking rectangles.
We're putting a whole bunch
of rectangles in one pocket
and then a bunch of
rectangles another pocket.
We can switch back and
forth however we want.
But the only way to
win, it turns out,
is if you get all
of those rectangles
to add up to exactly
the right height.
Then you get a
picture like this.
If you don't get a
picture like this,
you can prove you end up dying.
Then I'll give
you a bunch of Ls.
Then I'll finally give you this
T, which clears some lines.
And then I'll give you--
the most satisfying
Tetris game ever--
I'll give you a
ton of I's, and you
get Tetris, Tetris, Tetris,
and you clear the entire board.
And so if you can solve
the 3-partition problem
you can clear the
board and win the game
and be the best
Tetris player ever.
And if there is no
solution to 3-partition,
you're guaranteed to lose.
And so this proves
Tetris is NP-hard.
Cool.
So what else do I
want to say, briefly?
I think that's the main idea.
So another example--
so this spot
is called EXP-completeness.
And this includes problems
such as n by n chess.
So we know that chess
requires exponential time
because, in fact,
it's among the hardest
problems in exponential time.
But most common are the--
that's somehow because of the
two-player nature of the game.
Most common are
NP-complete problems.
And we have a bunch of
example NP-complete problems
I'll just briefly mention here.
So we saw the
subset sum problem,
which we had a polynomial
time algorithm for--
sorry, a pseudo polynomial
time algorithm for last class--
in fact has no polynomial
time algorithm,
assuming P equals NP.
So pseudo poly is the best you
can hope for for subset sum.
There's a related notion
called weakly NP-hardness,
which I won't get into here.
3-partition is one we saw.
We saw some reductions
to other problems.
So these are all NP complete.
Longest common subsequence is
another dynamic programming
problem we saw
with two sequences.
I mentioned you could
solve it for three
or four or any constant number.
But if I give you n
sequences each of length n,
that problem is
NP-hard, NP-complete.
Longest simple path
in a graph-- we
know how to solve longest path.
You just solve shortest
path and negative weights.
But longest simple path, where
you don't repeat vertices,
that's NP-complete.
Relatedly, one of the most
famous NP-complete problems
is traveling salesman
problem, finding
the shortest path that visits
all vertices in a given graph.
So instead of just
going from A to B,
I want to visit all the
vertices in the graph.
A lot of these
problems I'm phrasing
as optimization problems.
But when I say
NP-complete, I actually
mean a decision
version of the problem.
For example, with this
one, the decision question
is, is the shortest path that
visits all vertices in a graph
less than or equal
to a given value x.
If you can solve this,
then by binary search
you can solve the
overall weight.
3-coloring a graph is hard,
even though 2-coloring a graph
is polynomial.
3-coloring is NP-complete.
Assigning three
colors to the vertices
so that no adjacent vertices
have the same color,
finding the largest clique
in a given graph, which
would be useful for analyzing
social networks, whatever.
This is a fun one
for me as a geometer.
If you're in a three-dimensional
world, which I am,
and I want to find the shortest
path from here to there that
doesn't collide
with any obstacles,
like this desk and all the
chairs and so on, in 3D,
this problem--
if you can fly, so if
you're a drone flying
among all these
obstacles, you want
to find the shortest path from
A to B, this is NP-complete.
It's quite surprising.
In two dimensions,
it's polynomial.
You can reduce it to
graph shortest paths.
But in 3D, it's NP-hard.
This is a formula problem
that comes up a lot.
Given a Boolean formula
with AND, OR, or NOT,
can you ever make it true,
if it has some variables that
are not assigned?
And some more fun examples
are Minesweeper or Sudoku.
Basically any paper and pencil
puzzle you've ever played,
there's probably
a paper out there
proving that it's NP-complete.
And on the video game
side, Super Mario Brothers
is NP-hard.
Legend of Zelda is NP-hard.
Pokemon is NP-hard.
These problems are actually all
a little bit harder than NP,
in a different class called
P-space, which I won't go into.
But if you're interested
in this stuff,
there is a whole class devoted
to it, which has online video
lectures, so you can watch
them whenever you want,
called 6.892, that gives
a bunch of especially fun
examples of NP-hardness
and other types of hardness
proofs from a sort of
algorithm perspective for lots
of games and puzzles
you might care about.
And that's it.